>> Without further ado,
let's bring out the band.
Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up for One Republic.
[applause and cheering]
♪ [rock music]
>> Yeah.
>> Mm. Feel right.
Just kidding.
>> Welcome, guys.
You know, I wanted to start off just by
saying -- I was talking a little bit --
when you guys were
in the Green Room --
how much we, here at Google,
really appreciate your support in what
we're trying to do here with music.
It's a humble and modest start.
Our goal is really about kind of closing
that gap between you -- the artist
and your music -- and our millions
and millions of end users.
So, since Day One,
when we called you guys up and pitched
this idea what we're working on,
having not even had a chance to see it
or play with it or do a music search,
you jumped right on board,
lended your support,
came down for an amazing,
amazing launch event in West Hollywood.
And we really appreciate that. How
about a hand for these guys for that?
Really appreciate it.
[applause and cheering]
That really makes this whole thing complete.
Thanks a lot.
So, you know,
what we wanted to do is,
just open this up to a
little bit of a conversation.
I'm excited about the new album.
I definitely want to talk about that.
But, I want to go back to the beginning for
some of the people here in the audience.
Ryan, Zach -- maybe you guys can give us
a little bit of a peek into the early days
of One Republic and how it came to be.
And how you're sort of getting to today.
>> Soccer.
It's all about soccer.
>> Yeah.
Well, yes. I think a lot of people know,
but not everyone knows it.
Ryan and I went to high school together
in Colorado Springs, Colorado.
And it was senior year.
I'd already been there one
year from the Chicago area.
And, senior year, Ryan came in
from Oklahoma
and scored three goals
on the first game.
So, at that point,
I was like, "Dude, I'm going to
hang out with this guy."
So, you know, at that point,
we were in high school,
and we had like dreams and aspirations --
talked about music and someday
like doing the band thing.
And back then,
it was just high school like,
"Let's do a band!" You know.
After high school,
he went to separate college,
worked on songwriting and
a bunch of other things.
I went to a different college.
Actually tried engineering for
a couple years -- aeronautical.
And I didn't have the focus for that,
so props to all of you all who are
engineers in this building. [laughter]
So then, after that,
we kind of you know,
Ryan worked on --
like I said -- songwriting.
I couldn't figure out what I was doing.
I ended up in Chicago and --
fast forward --
Ryan called and was talking to
me about some of the people
he had worked with -- Timbaland,
being one of them.
So he had a really good start
to everything in terms of, you know,
"I know some people.
I know Timbaland,
blah, blah, blah.
And here's some songs
I've been working on."
And I was completely on board, so.
Then it went,
fast forward to L.A.,
and I let someone else field that,
but L.A. was a whole another ball
of wax to conquer for us.
>> So can you.
>> What?
>> And so can you.
>> And we'll see you there.
[chuckles]
>> So, let's fast forward a little bit, right?
"Dreaming Out Loud",
incredible album --
one of my favorites.
And one of the things that I noticed
that just blew me away
in surfing around online and looking
at your online presence.
And naturally,
I check out all your videos on YouTube.
And I was sort of surprised,
but I guess I shouldn't have been.
But, even these numbers start to kind of set
a new order of magnitude for the digital era.
Where, you know, in the old days --
or I guess even today.
We're still tracking gold and
platinum and diamond albums.
But I noticed that "Apologize",
one of your awesome tracks
off of that album has, in fact,
now gotten over 130 million views
on YouTube,
which is just incredible.
I don't know if there's a number for that,
some kind of like,
'sapphire' or.
>> Take back Garth Brooks.
>> That's right.
I mean, it's a completely different order.
>> He just said,
it's either adamantium or titanium.
[laughter]
>> Right.
>> Diamond is technically ten million,
so it's probably adamantium.
I think that's what it is.
>> Well, we've got to come up with
something for it, because, you know,
this is the new world order.
And you were telling me an
interesting story about that.
In the early days of the band,
and using the web and the Internet
as really a key marketing component
to getting OneRepublic, you know,
in the minds of your fans.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
>> Yeah. It's kind of ironic that I somehow ended
up with a degree in advertising and marketing,
and I never thought I was
actually going to use it.
And, you know, when you're broke,
and you're trying to get
something off the ground,
'free' is always a really good incentivizer.
So, when MySpace --
Drew signed us up for MySpace when
it had what -- like four, five million users.
>> That was like 2003 or 2004
or something.
>> Yeah. It was kind of one
of those deals, kind of like--
I remember the first time
somebody told me about Google,
I was using, you know, back in --
that was my R.A. of my junior year.
So it was like 2000,
something like that, '99.
If you wanted to find something,
you'd go to Lycos,
then you go to Yahoo,
then you'd go to Microsoft, you know,
you go to all the different searches.
And he said, "You got to use --
this kind of puts it all together."
MySpace was kind of like
that for us musically,
because it was free and
it had this sense of like,
the numbers were doubling every
month -- twice as many users,
if not more.
And the whole thought that I could just
have basically access to a database
of tens of millions of people for free.
So we just started working it every day.
We would e-mail --
this was before -- I didn't know how to
do spam or any of that, so I would --
>> Yeah, I think that was actually before.
>> That was before spam.
>> Yeah, we lucked out.
At the time that we kind of jumped on like,
Internet self-promotion as a band,
it was right before that big wave of a
bunch of like really spam bots and like,
pretty much everything that ran, you know?
Like shameless self-internet
promotion into the ground.
We sort of got in right
before that happened.
And that was a big part of, you know,
like our crusade like actually
have any authenticity.
>> It was a new technology or a new,
you know,
it was better than --
what was the thing before?
Friend space, or?
>> Well, there was MP3.com
and there was--
>> Pure Volume,
and then MySpace.
>> Yeah there was that.
That sort of void.
And we jumped on it.
>> Yeah, and it just kind of spread like,
by word of mouth.
And since there wasn't much
spamming going on,
everybody every time they
get an e-mail from us,
they thought, "Oh, this dude
is e-mailing me, you know?"
It was genuine. It was like
people reaching out to people.
And so, we quickly climbed the --
I remember the first day
we got 5000 spins in a day.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
5000 people getting e-mails from like
Romania and stuff like that."
And then, 50,000
and then 100, 000.
And we were getting --
we didn't have a record deal,
and we're getting 100,000 plays
a day on MySpace.
So that was, at that point --
we were the top-ranked unsigned act
on MySpace for almost a year.
>> Wow.
>> And every label started calling us.
And we'd already been dropped
by a record label at that point. So we,
yeah -- MySpace,
I've said this at the, you know,
Google Music Launch the other day,
and I mean it.
This band wouldn't be around if
it weren't for that technology--
for that, you know, interface --
because that was the only validation
we had when we got dropped.
We were like,
"Well, I guess that's it."
And then, boom!
We exploded on the Internet.
And it was like,
"Okay, it's working."
you know, screw the record labels --
people actually want to hear this.
And yeah.
The rest is history.
>> Well, the other funny thing
about certain building,
like building up our grassroots
movement like from there is,
it kind of was really difficult to go beyond
like a specific vehicle like MySpace,
because we were completely unsearchable
before we changed our name,
which was originally, "Republic."
And had it not been for countless hours of
not being able to find ourselves on Google
because there's a lot more important stuff
in the world with the name 'republic' in it.
>> China.
China being one of them.
>> Like Republic of China.
[laughter]
>> We literally had the discussion,
>> Or Banana Republic.
>> "How popular do we have to get
to be more popular than China?"
[laughter]
and the answer was two billions.
Yeah too popular.
Billions, Billions of popular.
[laughter]
>> So thank you, Google, for motivating
the change to 'OneRepublic'.
>> All right.
>> Give yourselves a hand.
[applause and cheering]
>> So what's the strategy now?
Next album is, "Dropping" what?
"Tomorrow"? Is that right?
Wake you up.
>> Tomorrow.
>> Fantastic.
Any inspiration now on how you guys
take your kind of 'digital crusade'
forward in 2009, 2010?
Knowing everything you learned
from kind of the MySpace days
and that experience to, is there another
sort of web assault in the works?
>> Well, we are -- some of you
may not know this,
but we are sitting in the lobby of the
largest Internet company of the world, so.
>> That's not a bad start.
>> It's a good place to start.
>> And that's just our 9:30.
[laughter] Yeah.
>> We go from here to Russia.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Where we talk to the whole country.
>> We're doing some Twitter stuff.
We're doing some MySpace -- we've
kind of kept that relationship.
So MySpace is launching it.
>> Right.
>> I mean, our goal at this point like --
it's cool if you sell physical albums,
because some people still,
you know, people obviously still
listen to that. It's nice getting a CD.
I like that too.
But like,
for us, our audience -- I mean,
like the more we can plug into digital,
you know, the better.
I'm trying to get to a --
I've had this idea for awhile.
And I know the technology exists
out there to make this happen.
But I'd love to be at a place with us
somewhere during the course of this
album where let's say, I mean --
these are just some of the ideas
that we're trying to push forward for us.
Let's say, you know,
you're halfway through a concert,
or you're opening up for a much
bigger act and by the end of the show,
right when you've got
everybody kind of worked up,
you can huh?
>> No somebody.
It doesn't matter.
You know how many freaking smarter
people there are in this building than me?
Like they haven't thought of it?
>> Right.
>> Honestly.
They already know what I'm about to say.
Seriously, it's like Google ESP.
>> And he's right, right?
We should have this.
>> It's a new Googlebot.
So I would love to be able to like say,
you know, text these
three numbers to 1R1R,
and this album, you're sent a link --
automatically download it to your iPhone,
to your, you know, Droid,
to whatever.
And, you know, there's -- we definitely
want to be on the forefront of technology,
because that's -- for us,
that was what created,
you know, our universe at this point.
>> Yeah, and I think it's that
immediacy, you know.
Like straight from a live performance
to the rest of the world
that's not at the show, right?
>> I was going to say,
when I was in high school,
when I was in high school,there
was only, really, two big avenues
that I would ever find out about music.
Obviously, one is friends.
And word of mouth is always
going to be massive.
The other was just radio, you know?
If you heard a song you liked,
you would hope --
I always hope like,
I hope the DJ comes on after that
and tells me who that was.
If not, there's no way I'm going to know.
I'm going to have to listen to the
radio again and wait for him to go,
"And that was the Swallow with their
new single Counting Blue Cars."
And I'll be like, "Oh, I got it."
And I'd run to Best Buy, and get it.
But now, music is everywhere.
You could see a commercial.
"I love that song," you know?
Who cares what the car is.
Or watch CSI,
or go online,
or -- you're hearing music
constantly and everywhere.
So, for us I think,
one of the big things that we rely on is,
for example, this Google thing.
So that fans when they're
confused or when they don't know,
"Whose song is that?"
"Apologize" was one of them.
People loved it.
They didn't.
We ran into the problem a lot where
people didn't quite know it was us.
They were like,
"Oh, 'Apologize', that's your song?"
And now, relying on this immediacy,
this like --
because fans are hearing it
from all kinds of avenues,
and they don't want to wait
too long to find out who it is.
So they're going to run to the Internet,
and they're going to want
that instant answer.
So you guys are actually
helping us with that.
Thank you.
>> Awesome.
Well, we're super-excited about it.
And you know, it's really
just the beginning,
I think, for figuring out ways that we
can just connect the world faster.
You know, we're doing some of
those demos over in the lobby,
and you can see how fast the Internet
traffic is moving around the world
and how searches are
being done worldwide.
We're just getting started here in the U.S.,
but I think this is a real --
it's a big, global opportunity as well.
You know, I want to ask you
one last question.
Just I'm curious because communication
is so pervasive now, right?
There's smart phones.
Every phone has a video camera.
Everybody's recording
everything that's going on.
It's basically like,
your life is always 'on' somewhere,
you know, in realtime.
And what's your take on
that content, right?
Because you've got fans. I mean,
everybody's there with their glowing --
you can see their blue screens
from their phone,
shooting pictures at concerts,
shooting video.
And it's flying all around the web.
Is that a good thing for you guys,
or how do you see that?
>> Honestly?
Or like, I mean,
it's weird.
From like, you know,
there's good and bad.
It's really great for like,
to feed the need for information.
Like, there's an interest out there,
you know, that people are,
you know, people are going to
want to see like,
whatever's going on with their
favorite band at any time if they can.
It kind of bums us out a little bit,
just because I think it's
killing the art of storytelling.
And you know,
just this sort of --
>> Mystery is gone.
>> -- living in the moment.
You know, if everything is done
for the sake of broadcasting it.
But you kind of have to go with the
times and what people like doing.
And so, yeah.
Whoever can get on top of that
is kind of top dog in 2009.
>> I think it's exciting and
terrifying at the same time.
And I think there's a phrase
that my dad coined years ago.
He had a friend who -- it was his best
friend who read five newspapers a day.
Every morning, he read USA Today,
Wall Street Journal,
New York Post,
I mean, da-da-da-da.
And he always made a joke.
He says he has IDP,
"Information Deprivation Paranoia."
And literally, it sounds like a clinical
term, but I honestly think that --
I think it's exciting.
I also think that it can get scary,
because everybody --
we are getting --
I think there's an actual addiction
that's starting to take place
to being 'on' and not
being able to turn off.
The other day actually,
I turned off my Blackberry,
and I bought a cell phone.
Because it was just getting like 250 e-mails
a day to the point to where it's like --
you start realizing that you live
most of your life
finding out what other people are doing,
or responding to stuff, and like,
not enough time actually living your life.
At a certain point, it's like,
"I'm going to the bathroom, tweet."
I'm doing this, tweet.
[laughter]
And it's just 'this, this and this.'
And at a certain point,
I think it's necessary.
I think we're willing to take --
as a band -- and being,
you know, it's kind of like if,
you know, like even with music.
Production evolves.
The sound of things evolve.
In 1979, '80, '81,
if you didn't have a disco song
on your album,
you weren't really selling records.
And so, you had acts that were not
disco acts that were putting out --
that were accommodating that,
because that's where it was.
And so, I look at it as that,
"it is where it is right now."
And it's phenomenal to be
able to do a show and boom!
-- it's everywhere, and the whole world
can see, because that's what they want
and that works.
I guess my only question and fear is,
I hope it doesn't get to a point,
you know -- I don't follow Miley Cyrus,
shockingly, but.
I don't follow her.
But the other day, when she made this
huge statement about, "I'm not tweeting,
because I'm realizing that
I'm literally just like --
at a certain point, you're like,
What am I doing?
Why am I doing this?
And so, we kind of -- we've had this debate
with us, because we love technology.
There's a certain point where,
if it gets invasive enough,
it kind of freaks me out.
It gets a little George Orwell
for me at a certain point.
So yeah, that's our take.
>> Well, I don't want to hog up
the microphone.
What I'd love to do,
in anticipation of getting you guys to jam
is turn to the crowd out here
for a few questions.
>> So, as artists, does it bother you that
almost all the online music distribution
is selling Lossy versions of your work?
>> Sorry, selling what?
>> Lossy versions, like compressed.
>> Oh, compressed versions.
Yeah, I think it's, for audiophiles,
you know, especially drives them nuts.
And, for us,
a very frustrating thing is,
the amount of money
you spend on gear --
on like microphones from the 40's
that can't be replaced
and like the best-sounding audio
equipment on earth --
only to have it crushed down
to a file this big,
because if you were to sit.
>> And that's the legal version.
>> That's the legal version too.
>> That's not even counting like,
all the people running around
with like whatever 64 meg like.
>> You know what the thing is, though?
If that's what your paradigm is --
if you're used to 192 -- or let's say,
3.5-megabyte file size of music --
and you've never sat around listening
on Generac speakers to a,
you know, hundred megabyte wav file,
which is what CDs essentially are,
you don't know the difference.
And so, ultimately,
from a perfectionist standpoint
and artistic standpoint,
it is frustrating,
but fortunately, people want it.
CDs are still pretty decent quality.
You can go out and buy a CD.
>> If you're over the age of 20, 28.
>> And you actually know what you are.
>> I remember that.
>> That's the funny thing.
The funny thing is-
It is going to be --
I'm going to say five years --
five years from now,
there will be kids -- everyone in this
room will see at some point --
a nephew, a niece, a cousin,
who literally picks up a CD,
and goes like, "What this?"
You know, like, you're going to
have that happen.
I mean, like if you show a 13-year-old
now a cassette tape, it's,
"What the hell is this?"
You know what I mean?
It's like when I saw an 8-track.
I was seven years old.
And I was just like -- I didn't
even know what to do with it.
I thought it was like an Atari
game or something. [laughter]
You know, the fact that I remember
8-tracks is actually weird, but.
Yeah, that's going to happen,
and eventually --
everything is cyclical, though.
I mean, that's the same thing
with tweeting.
Any time you have like a convergence
of all these technologies
that explodes into like this
Information Deprivation Paranoia,
which most people in this room
probably have some degree of -- I do.
Like, you get that e-mail,
read it right then,
you got to respond, etc.
At a certain point,
I think any time anything in technology
goes to an extreme
and speeds up and reaches
maximum velocity,
there's going to be a recoil.
And I'm really curious to
see what the recoil is.
>> All analog.
>> Yeah, it's going to go back to LPs.
It's going to go back to something.
I don't know what it is.
Both musically,
and I think communicating.
Watch two/three years from now,
all of a sudden, you know,
the sale of pens go up,
because people start writing letters again.
I mean, honestly,
who knows.
>> All right.
Anymore questions?
I think they all are dying
to hear you guys play.
And I really appreciate you
guys giving us the time,
making the effort to come out
here and fly out and visit us.
And I'm excited.
So let's get to it guys.
>> Let's do this!
[applause]
>> Is Mark standing over there?
Can I get some hot tea, man?
Can you do a search for that for me, please?
[tuning instruments]
>> Has anybody else --
I actually got nauseous
for about ten minutes,
seriously, after doing the Google Earth
thing that you guys have. [laughter]
Anyone else get nauseous doing that?
I'm not joking.
I was like -- he's like,
"Now find Denver, and fly into it.
And rotate 360-degrees."
And I did it, and I was just like
"There's my house." [laughter]
And yeah, guacamole was a bad idea.
[laughter]
>> Guacamole.
>> It is good guacamole, though.
You guys have really, really good food.
>> Okay, so we're going to
do some songs.
Each of these will be approximately
60 megabytes. [laughter]
64-megabytes in file form.
♪ [strumming guitar]
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ This town is colder now,
♪ I think it's sick of us
♪ It's time to make our move,
I'm shakin off the rust
♪ I've got my heart set
on anywhere but here
♪ I'm staring down myself,
counting up the years steady hands,
♪ just take the wheel...
♪ Every glance is killing me
♪ Time to make one last appeal...
♪ for the life I lead
♪ Stop and stare
♪ I think I'm moving but I go nowhere
♪ And yeah, I know that
everyone gets scared
♪ But I've become what I can't be,
♪ oh stop and stare
♪ You start to wonder
why you're 'here' not there
♪ And you'd give anything
to get what's fair
♪ But fair ain't what you really need
♪ Oh, can you see what I see
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ They're trying to come back,
♪ all my senses push
un-tie the weight bags,
♪ I never thought I could...
♪ Steady feet, don't fail me now
♪ I'm gonna run till you can't walk
♪ But something pulls my focus out
♪ And I'm standing down...
♪ Stop and stare I think
I'm moving but I go nowhere
♪ And yeah, I know that
everyone gets scared
♪ But I've become what I can't be,
♪ oh stop and stare
♪ Stop to wonder why
you're here not there
♪ And you'd give anything
to get what's fair
♪ But fair ain't what you really need
♪ Oh no, you don't need
♪ Ooh...
♪ What you need, what you need...
♪ Stop and stare
♪ I think I'm moving but I go nowhere
♪ And yeah, I know that
everyone gets scared
♪ But I've become what I can't be
♪ Oh, do you see what I see...
[applause and cheering]
>> Thank you.
>> All right.
>> Okay.
This normally has a really, really big,
booming bass and beat.
Have to check out.
Yeah.
One thing.
We recorded this in Johannesburg
while we were on tour,
and we finished it in Denver.
And it's a lot of fun.
It's called, "Everybody loves me."
♪ [rhythmic hand drums]
♪ [music playing]
♪ Well Hails sees her shadow
in my backseat
♪ And her friends are standing
right in front of me.
♪ Worldwide from the center burning turkey.
♪ Open up,
said everyboday loves me.
♪ You don't have to make a sound.
♪ They got what you need.
♪ What you need.
♪ Oh, oh.
♪ Oh-oh-oh.
♪ Gotta love all the people
that have warn you.
♪ Got to love all your sentimental virtue.
♪ Eight calls for the takers
that'll make you.
♪ Late calls for the lovers that'll hate you.
♪ And you don't have to make a sound.
♪ They got what you need.
♪ Oh-ohh-oh-ohhhh.
♪ Make you say, "Oh my."
♪ Feels just like I don't try
♪ Look so good I might die.
♪ All I know is,
♪ Everybody loves me.
♪ Get down.
♪ Swaying to my own sound.
♪ Flashes in my face now.
♪ All I know is everybody loves me.
♪ Everybody loves me, yeah.
♪ [music playing]
♪ Well I play the music don't stop
till I turn gray
♪ Starts with ever light,
♪ John Susan never fade.
♪ He had a beautiful child
named Desiree.
♪ Hope I'm remembered for
the thanks that I'm never made.
♪ You don't have to make a sound.
♪ They got what you need.
♪ Oh, yeah.
♪ You say, oh, my.
Feel just like I don't try.
♪ I look so good I might die.
♪ All I know is,
♪ Everybody loves me.
♪ Head down.
♪ Swaying to my own sound.
♪ Flashes up my face now.
♪ All I know is,
♪ Everybody loves me.
♪ Everybody.
Everybody. Oh.
Everybody.
You don't need my health.
Got my name, you got my wealth.
I stare at the sun just for kicks
all by myself.
I lose track of time so
I might be past my prime.
But I'm feeling oh so good.
Yeah.
Oh, my.
It's just like I don't try.
Looks so good I might die.
All I know is,
Everybody loves me.
Head down.
Swaying to my own sound.
Flashes in my face now.
All I know is,
Everybody loves me.
Eee-ohh.
Yeah.
Everybody.
Don't you know where you are?
I say, everybody,
everybody.
Wo-ohh!
[cheering and applause]
>> Thank you.
>> Okay.
This next song is called "Secrets."
Yeah, this is our first single in Europe,
actually, in Germany.
It just hit number one yesterday, actually.
[cheering and applause]
>> We bumped up Mr. Robby Williams.
[laugher]
>> Proud of that, man.
>> He had that rock/DJ song.
He's not that big over here.
I don't know why.
He should be;
don't you think, Drew?
>> Yeah.
All right, well.
>> Drew is totally into that.
>> We're waiting for Take That to --
oh, they're having a reunion right now.
He just announced it -- all
you Take That fans out there.
>> Take that.
Which is?
This song's called "Secrets."
Hope you like it.
Anytime guys.
Anytime.
♪ [fingering guitar]
>> There it is.
>> How's that?
>> Feels good.
>> Let's go with it.
>> Yeah. I like that.
♪ I need another story
♪ Something to get off my chest
♪ My life gets kinda boring
♪ I need something that I can confess
♪ Til' all my sleeves are stained red
♪ From all the truth that I've said
♪ Come by it honestly I swear
♪ Thought you saw me wink, no
♪ I've been on the brink, so
♪ Tell me what you want to hear
♪ Something that'll light those ears
♪ We're sick of all the insincere
♪ So I'm gonna give all my secrets away
♪ This time, don't need
another perfect line
♪ Don't care if critics ever jump in line
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away
♪ My God,
♪ amazing how we got this far
♪ It's like we're chasing all those stars
♪ Driving shiny, big, black cars, yeah.
♪ And everyday I see the news
All the problems that we could solve
♪ And when a situation rises
just write it into an album
Seen it straight, too cold
♪ I don't really like my flow,
♪ So tell me what you want to hear
♪ Something that'll light those ears
♪ We're sick of all the insincere
♪ So I'm gonna give all my secrets away
♪ This time, don't need another perfect line
♪ Don't care if critics ever jump in line
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away
Oh,
♪ [music playing]
♪ got no reason, got not shame
♪ Got no family I can blame
♪ Just don't let me disappear
I'ma tell you everything
♪ Tell me what you want to hear
♪ Something that'll light those ears
♪ We're sick of all the insincere
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away
♪ This time, don't need another perfect line
♪ Don't care if critics ever jump in line
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away
Tell me what you want to hear
♪ Something that'll light those ears
♪ We're sick of all the insincere
♪ So I'm gonna give all my secrets away
♪ This time, don't need another perfect line
♪ Don't care if critics ever jump in line
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away -
♪ ooh
♪ Gonna give all my secrets away
♪ I'll give all my secrets --
tell me what you want to hear.
[cheering and applause]
>> Thank you.
♪ [cello]
♪ I remember, I remember
when I lost my head, yeah.
♪ I knew there was something
so special about that place
♪ Even your emotions have an echo.
♪ So much fades.
♪ Mmm.
♪ And when you're out there, okay
Yeah, I was out of touch
♪ But it wasn't because I didn't know enough
♪ I just knew too much, ohh.
♪ Does that make me crazy?
♪ possibly
♪ And I hope that should happen
the time of your life
♪ But think twice
♪ But that's my only advice
♪ ohh.
♪ Yeah,
♪ and who do you,
who do you,
♪ Who do you, who do you,
who do you feel you are?
♪ Well, heh, heh heh
♪ Well bless my soul
You really think you're in control?
No, no.
I think you're crazy.
I think you're crazy
just like me.
I think you're crazy.
I think you're crazy just like me.
Ooh...
♪ [music playing]
♪ Eleanor Rigby
♪ there's na... [laughter]
♪ nobody came.
>> I always forget these lyrics.
If you know them, sing them.
♪ All the lonely people
♪ Where do they all come from?
♪ Where do they all belong?
♪ I think we're crazy.
♪ I think we're crazy --
all of us, just like me.
I think you're crazy.
I think you're crazy just like me.
just like me.
Hey.
[cheering and applause]
>> Yeah.
Can I get some more of this, please?
Preferably the ginger green mint.
[laughter]
Without honey, sans lemon.
>> Don't get the jasmine.
The jasmine --
>> This one's drying my throat out.
>> -- is making you really hyper.
>> I told you I don't do black tea.
I don't know how many times I
have to say I don't do black tea.
I don't do black tea.
[laughter]
You can Google that.
>> Let's Google the tour manager
too and see what happens.
>> I'm sure there's plenty.
>> I'm just kidding.
[laughter]
>> That wasn't very nice.
>> Mark and I have an understanding.
It's cool. Yeah.
>> So, okay.
Yeah.
Let's do the next one down.
Enough steam for two more.
♪ [syncopated percussion]
♪ Let's paint the picture
Of the perfect place
♪ They've got it better than
when anyone's told ya
♪ They'll be the King of Hearts,
and your the Queen of Spades
♪ Then we fight for you like
we were your soldiers
♪ I know we've got it good
But they've got it made
♪ And the grass is getting greener each
day I know things are looking up,
♪ soon they'll take us down
Before anybody's knowing our name
♪ They've got...
♪ All the right friends in
all the right places
♪ So yeah, we're going down
♪ They've got all the right
moves and all the right faces
♪ So yeah, we're going down
♪ Everybody knows,
everybody knows where we're going
♪ Yeah, we're going down
♪ They say Everybody knows,
everybody knows where we're going
♪ Yeah, we're going down
♪ Do you think I'm special?
♪ Do you think I'm nice?
♪ Am I bright enough to shine in your spaces?
♪ Between the noise you hear,
and the sounds you like
♪ Are we just sinking in the ocean of faces?
♪ It can't be possible...
the rain could fall
♪ Only when it's over our heads.
The sun is shining everyday --
that's funny -- but it's miles away.
Over the world it's dead.
They've got,
they've got...
All the right friends in
all the right places
So yeah, we're going down
They've got all the right
moves and all the right faces
So yeah, we're going down
Everybody knows, everybody knows
where we're going
Yeah, we're going down
They say everybody knows, everybody
knows where we're going
Yeah, we're going down
♪ [music playing]
♪ Mr. Computer,
♪ you ain't even workin'
♪ Though I know what you
see I know I can never be
♪ Someone that will look like you
♪ Don't matter what you know [laughing]
♪ Can never sound like you one, two, say
♪ All the right friends in all the right places
♪ So yeah, we're going down they've got
♪ All the right moves
and all the right faces
♪ Yeah, we're going down
♪ All the right friends in
all the right places
♪ So yeah, we're going down they've got
♪ All the right moves and all the right faces
♪ Yeah, we're going down I say
♪ Everybody knows, everybody
knows where we're going
♪ Yeah, we're going down I say
♪ Everybody knows, everybody knows
where we're going
♪ Yeah, we're going down
♪ Oh, ooh...
♪ Oh, ohh...
♪ Yeah, we're going down
♪ They've got all the right moves,
hey..
♪ Yeah, we're going down
♪ They've got all the right moves
hey..
♪ Yeah, we're going down
♪ [music playing]
>> Yeah.
[cheering and applause]
>> Thank you.
[more applause]
>> Sweet.
That's some technology right there.
[laughter]
You guys stole that from Lycos?
Sorry. Internet search engine jokes.
Sometimes they don't --
so yeah, let's do one more.
And you guys can go change the world.
[rhythmic hand drums]
>> It's interesting.
♪ [music playing]
♪ I'm holding on your rope
Got me ten feet off the ground
♪ And I'm hearing what you say
But I just can't make a sound No..
♪ You tell me that you need me
Then you go and cut me down
♪ But wait...
♪ You tell me that you're sorry
Didn't think I'd turn around and say..
♪ That it's too late to apologize,
♪ it's too late I said it's
too late to apologize,
♪ it's too late
Oh..
♪ I'd take another chance, take a fall,
take a shot for you oh..
♪ And I need you like a heart needs a beat
(But it's nothing new)
♪ Yeah oh..
♪ I loved you with a fire red,
now it's turning blue
♪ And you say
♪ Sorry like the angel heaven
let me think was you
♪ But I'm afraid
It's too late to apologize,
♪ it's too late I said it's too late
to apologize, it's too late
♪ Oh-ooh
♪ [music playing]
♪ ooh ooh
♪ It's too late to apologize,
♪ it's too late I said it's too late to apologize,
♪ it's too late
♪ It's too late to apologize,
♪ yeah yeah
♪ I said it's too late to apologize,
wo ooh
♪ I'm holding on your rope
Got me ten feet off the ground
[cheering and applause]
>> Thank you.
>> Cheers and applause.
Applause. Thank you.
Continue to applause. Thank you.
>> Cheers and applause.
>> Apple sauce.
>> Continue to applause.
Thank you.
>> Cheers and apple sauce.
>> Continue to applause.
>> Apple sauce.
>> Cheetos and apple sauce.
>> I got more flavors than
biggie at Baskin Robbins.
>> This is amazing.
>> Google. Google. Google. Google. Google.
>> Okay. Thank you, guys,
for having us out.
>> Yeah, it's too much fun.
>> And that's Brent on the carbon
fiber cello, guys.
That was awesome.
[cheering]
>> We'll see you again.
Come visit us, guys.
Love having you.
>> Thank you.